let's go next to our caller from the 6-3
one area code who's calling today from
631 hi David it's me yes it is hi um
this is spinny chair from Long Island
thanks boo TV before you go on if you
can put the phone a little further from
your mouth because you're absolutely
maxing out our system and it becomes
hard to hear just keep the phone a
little further away from your mouth
please try it from here oh I love it the
other day you had a video about social
democracy and populist and then I found
very interesting but I thought there was
more to flesh out because you yourself
you do have an anti-establishment
criticism you know you will criticize
what you call the Democratic
establishment and I think that's what
extent is populism so I don't know if
you can kind of square that circle
because you do engage in some populist
arguments but you do manage not to um I
guess fall off the deep end with it yeah
I I mean I guess I don't there's really
no conflict between so the analysis was
basically an analysis of it's harder to
pervert and bamboozle with social
democracy than with populism that was my
assertion essentially and as I said in
the video that doesn't mean left
populist ideas are wrong so the the way
that I square it is I believe in social
socially democratic policy and certainly
there are good left populist ideas and I
have some of those ideas but the
analysis was that it's very easy to
pervert populism and you end up with
right populism and it can even go into
authoritarianism
that was the analysis so I maybe I'm not
understanding the question but I don't
know there's anything too square also in
other words you wouldn't say that you
have a somewhat populist analysis but
that you don't go off the edge with it
like maybe a moderate populism you you
you were to say that you're just a
social democrat listen we're getting
into sort of like labeling everything I
I guess my general political views
economic
are of social democracy there is
certainly overlap in terms of many of
the goals with left populism but the
story was not so much about my views per
se but about the ways in which populist
rhetoric has been perverted in many
cases and ends up being something very
different than what's promised okay
well maybe if I could phrase it in a
different way
I just lost my train of thought I'll
head out now have a good day David all
right very good appreciate the phone
call great to hear from you yeah people
so we have dramatically improved our
phone system over the last two weeks
where we have a very small delay as
people can probably tell the only
downside is I have less of an ability
when that crunching sound happens it's
it's in the system it's not on my end so
people need to talk a little quieter and
maybe keep the phone a little further
away both very very important elements
of making a good phone call right now